الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه كانت اوكرانيا
احد عناوينها الرئيسيه التسريبات المصنفه
سريه للغايه وهي الابرز منذ عقد قد تؤدي
الى تعقيد العلاقه بين امريكا وحلفائها
وتحديدا كييف التي لجات الى تغيير خططها
العسكريه في اول تحرك بعد التسريبات
تفاصيل التي تم الكشف عنها في 50 صفحه
اظهرت كيف تتجسس الولايات المتحده في
الواقع على الاصدقاء والاعداء على حد سواء
اسرار مروعه تم الكشف عنها من بينها توصل
المخابرات الامريكيه الى مرتزق روسي مزعوم
يحاول الحصول على اسلحه من دوله عضو
بالناتو لاستخدام هذا ضد اوكرانيا الوثائق
المسربه توضح ايضا كيف تمكنت الولايات
المتحده من اختراق عمق الجيش الروسي ما
يمكنها بالفعل من تحذير اوكرانيا مسبقا
اذا ارادت ذلك ففي فبراير من هذا العام
وبحسب الوثائق المسربه كانت الولايات
المتحده على علم بان الجيش الروسي يعد
لهجوم على منشات الطاقه والجسور في
اوكرانيا لكنها التزمت الصمتحي لذلك
الوثائق كشفت ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني اس 300 من الحقبه السوفيتيه
ستنفد بحلول مايو الامر الذي اغضب
مسؤوليكييف الذين سعوا لاخفاء نقاط قوتهم
وضعفهم عن الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات